the zombies are like
eating everyone who doesn't love a good
spooky animated film yes whether it be
centering around a family that's creepy
and kooky a hotel for monsters run by
dracula and his daughter or a young boy
who was transported to the land of the
remembered some of your favorite actors
and actresses have lended their voices
to these popular spine-tingling animated
flicks
this is going to be harder than i
thought
the hotel transylvania movies boast
quite the impressive ensemble of actors
but mavis voiced by selena gomez has
always stood out as a fan favorite it
may surprise you that gomez almost did
not even voice mavis and that miley
cyrus was initially cast before her
gomez has expressed just how much fun
she has being a part of the
monster-filled franchise wow i can't
believe i'm actually here
adam sandler is one of the most popular
comedic actors in the world headlining
comedy movies such as happy gilmore
murder mystery and grown-ups as well as
many others though his most popular
franchise is perhaps hotel transylvania
welcome to hotel transylvania
adam sandler voiced the comical spin on
the iconic vampire for the first three
films alongside a cast of several of his
frequent collaborators director of the
films revealed that sandler signed on to
play dracula for his daughters as he
wanted to be part of a movie they could
watch and enjoy as a family no no no i
didn't mean to startle you my little
baby
dakota fanning had been making waves
even before she was cast as the title
character and like a stop-motion
adaptation of neil gaiman's coral line
fanning at the time had already starred
in adaptations of other popular books
for young readers such as charlotte's
web and the cat in the hat fanning was
originally planning to star as coraline
in a live action film but director henry
selick ultimately changed his mind and
went the animated route while recording
her lines fanning even had to record
grunting and falling sounds for her
character along with the dialogue
coraline
coraline jones
leica's 2012 stop-motion movie film
paranorman has quite the cast of quirky
yet lovable characters including pitch
perfect star anna kendrick who voices
courtney the older sister of the title
character paranorman was kendrick's
first animated film as it debuted four
years before the release of trolls where
she voiced the lovable poppy in
paranorman kendrick was able to channel
her inner teenage girl from crushing on
boys talking on the phone and being
annoyed by her little brother the film's
directors chris butler and sam fell even
encouraged kendrick to do a surprising
amount of improv and ad living what are
you gonna do ask the zombies not to eat
you johnny depp and tim burton were
making movies together left and right
when he was chosen to voice victor in
burton's stop-motion film corpse bride
despite being one of the biggest stars
in the industry at the time corpse bride
just so happened to be depp's first
voice acting role in a film having only
previously done voice work as a guest
for an episode of king of the hill a
year prior one of the biggest challenges
of doing voice work for corpse bride was
that depp wasn't able to put together
his own character like he had done for
jack sparrow despite that depp was still
able to put his own spin on victor
where is your chakra
pixar's oscar-winning coco features an
all latino voice cast in order to stay
true to the story's ties to the mexican
holiday dia de los muertos gael garcia
bernal known for his roles in old and
mozart in the jungle jumped at the
opportunity to voice hector as he saw
that the role would give him the
opportunity to be part of something that
his children could watch and enjoy
bernal had always been a fan of pixar
and was truly drawn to the project
because of the world the film builds and
the cultural elements
you're always this nervous before a
performance much of the cast of pixar's
coco is populated by well-known latino
actors but for miguel the film's
protagonist the creative team behind the
film opted to go for young newcomer
anthony gonzalez and i was just so
excited and i just
couldn't believe that i was gonna be in
the disney pixar films gonzalez was
extremely interested in the project
especially with the perseverance of the
main character as well as the films
taking place around dia de los muertos a
holiday his family has celebrated since
he was six years old
i don't i don't know i've never
performed before many across the
internet had always dreamed of oscar
isaac playing gomez adams in an atom
family movie so when he was cast as the
voice of the character in the 2019
animated film it was the perfect match
isaac knew he couldn't just use his
regular voice for the role of gomez and
that he really needed to capture the
creepy and kooky spirit of the character
now you're ready since gomez hails from
eastern europe that meant isaac had to
put on an accent in order to accurately
voice him there's definitely something
that's a little bit arch and theatrical
and presentational about him one of the
most well-known spooky themed animated
franchises out there is of course
scooby-doo the team behind the 2020
animated flick scoob brought on some
a-list talent to voice the iconic
characters including zac efron as fred
the head of the mystery solving monster
stomping mystery inc one of the reasons
why ephron was so attracted to scoob was
director tony cervone's passion for
scooby-doo which encouraged ephron to
channel his inner fred the mystery
machine needs a fresh coat of
everything
catherine o'hara is known for her iconic
roles such as moira in shit's creek and
mrs mcallister in home alone but you may
not have realized that she was also the
voice of sally in the holiday classic
the nightmare before christmas o'hara
described the experience as completely
different than anything she has ever
done in her career my dialogue was
patchwork together too with bits of
sentences constructed into sally speak
[Applause]
frankenweenie was tim burton's return to
the world of stop motion animation and
he was able to bring some of his
frequent collaborators with him winona
ryder was one of them who worked with
barton on films like beetlejuice and
edward scissorhands but you may know her
best from her role as joyce byers on
stranger things in frankenweenie ryder
voiced elsa van helsing the next door
neighbor and classmate of victor
frankenstein who in one particular scene
sings ryder actually got to work with
legendary composer danny elfman one on
one when recording her singing actually
work with him like directly just me and
him
was very exciting
12 years after the release of monsters
inc billy crystal reprised his role of
mike wazowski in the prequel monsters
university crystal has had an
illustrious career but out of all the
characters he has played crystal claims
that the short one-eyed monster is his
favorite character he's ever played
crystal loves the honesty and courage of
the character which made him jump at the
chance to play him again
this is gonna be harder than i thought
charlize theron is one of the most
popular actresses around the world and
her distinctive style and voice made her
the perfect fit as the addams family
matriarch morticia theron expressed her
admiration for the portrayal of morticia
in previous incarnations of the adams
family and described her as a stoic
loving and protective mother and wife
theron felt she didn't want to take away
what made morticia so special which led
her to embrace everything that made her
so popular in the first place
monsters vs aliens was actually reese
witherspoon's first ever animated film
which presented the oscar winner with
some challenges with her spoon was
unsure how she was supposed to act in
the film whether she was supposed to be
silly and hamming it up or serious but
she was able to get the hang of it soon
enough the hot line is really funny the
book of life was a surprise hit when it
hit theaters in the fall of 2014 with
channing tatum voicing joaquin one of
the three main characters alongside
diego luna and zoe zaldana tatum
definitely had a blast recording his
lines for the movie but he was a bit
disappointed that he wasn't able to
record his lines alongside saldana and
luna
from oscar winners to action stars and
a-list comedians actors and actresses of
all types have lent their voices to
these animated characters even brooklyn
99 star andy samberg joined in on the
fun as johnny in hotel transylvania
who's your favorite spooky animated
character